Speaker 1: Let's go next to Trey from
Missouri. Trey, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: I think. Well, thanks for taking the
call, Dave. I just had a quick question. So, you
know, one of the things that you've outlined is
that there are sort of three different Republican
groups. You've got the pro-business class, you
have the social conservatives. And then I can't
remember what was the other group. It's like the.
Speaker 1: Freedom libertarian people. Now,
I would add a fourth to that now, but maybe
that's where your question is going. So I'll
let you I'll let you ask the question first.
Speaker 2: Well, the question I was going to ask
is that, you know, Thom Hartmann, you know, had
mentioned that there was there was another sort of
a group that sometimes doesn't get a lot of
popularity. And it's that the group of people
who have a legitimate economic grievance about
their jobs being taken away from NAFTA, TPP and
all these other, you know, neoliberal trade deals.
And so I was wondering, is it is it possible that
if the Democrats can sharpen their message on
trade, jobs, protection, protections and whatnot,
that they could potentially get some of those
voters back who who voted for Trump in 2016
and only switched over to Biden
just after the last four years.
Speaker 1: Yes. Now, here's the thing. What we
would have to be concerned with is the group of
people you describe who aren't also part of
one of the three groups I mentioned and who
are more loyal to that than to the legitimate
economic grievance. Does that make sense? And
I can say more about that if it doesn't.
Speaker 2: I was just curious because like
I said, I know that it's unlikely that
we're going to help the people who are,
you know, the social conservatives or, you
know, the pro-business class, just because
we have different views economically
and socially than these people. Yeah,
but I figured that. That if we sharpen our
message, which I don't know how, because
the current mainstream Democratic Party is is
so feeble and not able to put a coherent message
together. Yeah, I thought that. That there was
going to be at least one possibility that we
could we could get the people back economically by
running on an economic populist agenda that says,
we're going to fight for your jobs. We're
done letting people take your jobs overseas.
And I feel like that might be a potential.
Speaker 1: So I would say one thing about that.
For me, the running on the populist messages left
and right, I'm not huge on it because populism
at the end of the day is a rhetoric. It's not a
set of policy ideas. So I'm basically with your
the the spirit of your message, but I'm less
interested in the so-called populist rhetoric
which can just go nowhere or be misused.
I'm more interested in just a coherent
pro middle class worker social democracy
policy. And where I am 100% behind you is
what you're saying that Democrats could do that
might appeal to some disaffected Republicans.
It should also appeal to center left people
who just don't vote because they don't see
the Democratic Party as having their back. So it's
not just the Republicans that that would target.
So so I think that that that better economic
message and policy, most importantly,
would actually appeal to disaffected centrists,
people on the left and some of these less
ideological Republicans that you talk about.
Speaker 2: And thanks for the call.
Speaker 1: Thank you. Trey Trey from
Missouri, very important phone call. I love it